i would like to procure from the
audience five random topics or phrases
and then i'll do a freestyle rap about
them if you are in the section i am
looking at right now what would you like
a rap about
oh no this is a conversation this isn't
this isn't heck wait did did someone
heckle before and they got really told
off are you all like no i've given you
permission
and i'm i'm like
your dad
wait are you making excuses for someone
oh that's okay
you're a dad you are a dad what's your
name dad yeah another dad
that's one of them are you matty you
simple i
simple as they get yeah no
dad's dads will own up to that they'd be
like no no i don't get things right
it was just it was just yeah matt the
dad okay matt what's your job software
software for which company
you don't buy any software from matt's
company
um
matt who matt the dad who has his own
software company that's the first
suggestion matt you're gonna be in the
wrap that's pretty exciting
yeah matt's excited this side you've now
had plenty of thinking time
and if any of you say carol the mom then
i will be very angry
would you like a rapper
tony blair you're not in that side but
that is that is a good suggestion that's
a real blast from the past for those who
don't know tony blair was the prime
minister of the united kingdom elected
in
1997 no younger than that maybe it was
before that maybe not anyway he's a
center-left labor party yeah we'll rap
about him um but you guys still have to
come up with something you're not off
the hook just because we've got matt the
software dad and tony blair yes a hand
up here
a ferris wheel falling off from rolling
away thank you you engineering
psychopath
i got a ticket to coney island we're
gonna have some fun
i'm at the software dad tony blair
ferris wheel falling off and rolling
away let's come to the kind of the mass
in the middle front of the room what
would you do lovely people like a rapper
okay um
i mean number one you're not in the bit
i pointed out number two i did kind of
say don't do foods um
however
falafel
is a good suggestion because it has a
special place in my heart one of my
favorite places i've ever been is a
falafel restaurant in the marie which is
the gay jewish district in paris
gay jewish district it's not
a very niche district in paris
really specific ghetto isn't it
um
and there's a restaurant called la
falafel and i love that because that is
a palindrome the le falafel reads the
same forwards as it does backwards
there's a matt cleverman over there who
got it yeah and a falafel is also like a
visual palindrome right because it looks
the same going in as it does coming out
okay
falafel falafel matt the software dad
ferris wheel falling off rolling away
tony blair in front of the room he stole
your suggestion so this is your chance
for the final one what would you like a
rap about
melania
melania trump well let's be i mean yeah
she's been out of the public eye for a
while but then i guess recently she did
that whole kind of
which is always fun um what what about
melania are you interested in and be
respectful now she is a lady
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no
okay
this this is uh it's going to be a
freestyle it's a wrap made up on the
spot to do that we need some music so if
my lovely uh dj could drop a beat and uh
we're going to have some fun are we yeah
oh smooth so yeah it's gonna be smooth
and lovely it'll be about a ferris wheel
falling off and rolling away melania
trump's thoughts tony blair matt the
software dad
falafel not yeast infection and um and
what was another one we had
okay well i thought i said that that's
fine we get it later maybe we can court
look at that melania slovenian what's in
her thoughts check her brain out usually
she's like this guy is so weird i know
the president 45 admittedly the accent
is up for discussion blushing with
embarrassment cause that sounded russian
but maybe she's an agent like deep
undercover maybe in five years fbi will
discover she was planted there yeah they
really need to weed all the way into the
white house a sleeper agents what it
called did she really take the reigns
baron trump every time you see him looks
insane like his whole passions drain
that's melania's son what are her
thoughts about this what will he become
he's grown up to like six foot five
maybe the best trump baller alive going
there on the court maybe she would say
tuck him in a night yes the nba is yours
for the taking you can shoot those
threes and everyone will be like well
baron jeez you're amazing we were so
mean at your dad apologies for all the
online hate you had melania's plan it
just comes to fruition meanwhile trump
he's in the position deep in the ground
probably dead how how does he feel he
was riding with rickety ferris wheel
right on the top he got to the circle
and then it went snapped to the ground
it hurtled he was like oh it broke his
body he was hurt you all and then it
rolled on squirting squirt more all of
the blood because it sprays like a
catherine wheel all the little things
splashing off try to feel some empathy
as it rolls to the ocean usually it's
downhill a sea level motion don't build
a little ferrous wheel on a mountain
otherwise it drips down yeah i'm
counting how many pieces of software
i've had that was so bad that clearly
made by matt the dad getting on the
laptop then it just froze everything
stopped and so i just go to my email
client maybe outlook or gmail send a
little message to the dad not a female
and say yeah it fails i need my license
back and matt's like don't worry chris
i'll have a crack i'll come round fixing
it no trouble he does the dad thing
where he stretches out his knuckles and
settles down there at the keyboard i'm
like matt that's the fridge are you sure
you sat at the right computer he's like
i apologize let me sit down here and try
this on for size i'm like again matt
that's not the laptop that's just some
taps and you turn it so they stop
dropping all the water he's so confused
but still you've got a nice little rap
about you in it fun mat don't you like
it when the raps fall what you gonna
treat yourself after falafel go down to
mac moods or the olive tree try and get
falafel in lebanon or you can eat maybe
out to beirut bringing those things
taken in my mouth and the munching
impinging on the hospitality with tahini
i put it on there and eat some sesame
and see me getting all my chickpeas mush
them in my pestle and mortar then i deep
fry don't add water or a fire might
happen if floats doesn't mix if you want
a sandwich well don't put your little
dick in there why because you'll collect
some bacteria and get the yeast
infection fun yeah i said i wouldn't rap
that ended doing like a two comic before
call back and now the last thing is he
up there well not in the morality area
tony blair why he went along with george
bush and colin powell invaded iraq yeah
we needed uk to allow they were backing
up their like the suggestion that saddam
hussein has the nuclear weapons they
fell in such a group of bad lads they're
going over there for the fall of baghdad
but tony blair well it's so many little
policies that worked and his wife called
sherry had a shortcut bob it was black
to the shoulders if you're not aware of
this i'm so glad that i told you i
couldn't finish with the thing about
matt but know about the pm in number one
oh number 10 that's the place where they
live in my country got a nice black door
tony blair he might hunt me down and say
chris that rap was great and i'm like
[ __ ] you why cause me and my mates we'd
be hanging out there bump into the sound
i'm like me and matt we can go up to the
fairground he's like oh yeah chris how
do you feel did you know i actually
designed this ferris wheel i'm like [ __ ]
matt no not today i know it's so shortly
constructed it will roll away and so
i'll leave him there feeling kind of
foolish but he doesn't die so matt you
[ __ ] rule this yeah
[Applause]